todos los días nos amen visita al museo
de rafa que dirigió durante 16 años su
trabajo porque no cuando la ciudad se ve
bajo el control del ejército libre
decidió en 2013
tuve un ataque cerebral para de eso la
mitad de mi cuerpo un librazo y pierna
[Música]
esto sucedió la noche que entraron en el
señor del plata
actualmente se encuentra mejor gracias a
los tratamientos que ha recibido pero el
dolor que le causa lo sucedido con el
museo lo atormenta hasta hoy
no
espero que esta tierra vuelva a ser
localidad
a día
para perdió su brazo en 2013 un año
después de comenzar a las protestas iban
un autobús hacia su casa cuando una
bomba lanzada por uno de los aviones del
ejército sirio lo alcanzó cuando resulte
herido me llevaron al hospital nacional
cuando estaba en el hospital lo
bombardearon
hasta entonces era un deportista
reconocido en la ciudad hoy prefiere
guardar bajo perfil
paso cuando camino por la calle no me
siento común el dolor que le causa su
invalidez hace que nunca quiera volver a
este gimnasio donde entrenaba para nunca
ha vuelto a ser la misma persona al
igual que millones de sirios que tienen
que convivir día a día con las heridas
psicológicas que ha dejado la guerra
el sheikh ali knife coordina con los
clérigos cómo ayudar a la reconstrucción
moral y psicológica de la ciudad a
través de mensajes que promuevan la
convivencia especialmente entre los
genios
desde su oficina cortina la enseñanza
del corán lo más cerca que un niño de
rata tiene para hablar de los problemas
mentales que confronta
lo que dejaron fue miedo en el alma de
todas las personas en raqa de todos el
impacto psicológico causado por la
guerra es incalculable pero los
problemas en traca son tantos que no
existen proyectos institucionales para
votar
[Música]